[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
David Diop est-ce que ce sont les
écrivains qui racontent le mieux la
alors l'Afrique peut être raconté par
tous ceux qui vivent je pense simplement
les écrivains
et et puis il a raconté à qui ça aussi
c'est une question peut-être que moi je
raconte l'Afrique à des gens qui n'y ont
jamais été mais c'est pas toute
l'Afrique c'est mon Afrique à moi c'est
votre Afrique à vous oui et chacun a une
expérience vraiment personnelle de
l'Afrique moi elle est liée à à mon
enfant à mon père ma mère il revient
ouais vous êtes franénégalais voilà donc
et puis est lié aussi à une époque parce
que ma jeunesse que j'y est passée et
bien elle s'éloigne vous avez fait
toutes vos études
là-bas les les premières études quoi
l'école primair oui l'école prima le
collège le lycée le lycée ou oui est-ce
qu'il y a pas une justement un paradoxe
aujourd'hui parce qu'on dit que
l'Afrique c'est le continent de
l'oralité le Sénégal singulièrement
celui des Grillot et il y a de plus en
plus d'écrivains qui racontent l'Afrique
justement pas uniquement au Sénégal bien
sûr mais partout alors il y a une foison
d'écrivains aujourd'hui hein oui oui
dans chaque pays après l'Afrique est
très grande mais dans chaque pays
africain il y a des écrivains
qui écrivent
l'Afrique qui la raconent comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure mais
contrairement à ce qu'on pense l'écrit
en tout cas en Afrique de l'Ouest existe
depuis très longtemps on a retrouvé des
des des textes et des manuscrits
manuscrit oui qui qui date au Mali et on
sait qu'au Sénégal par exemple il y
avait des transcriptions du wallof mais
avec l'alphabet arabe alors le wallof
c'est la langue la plus usitée en
Afrique en au Sénégal Sénégal oui c'est
une langue vernaculaire et donc l'écrit
est fort ancien en Afrique après
la pratique de la littérature de
l'écriture elle est elle est arrivée
sous la forme écrite évidemment au
moment de la colonisation mais je sais
mon père me le raconta qu'il y avait des
joutes de poètes et des improvisations
poétiques qui ne relevaient pas
simplement du griotisme qui
n'appartenait pas simplement au Grillot
et il y avait un goût pour la langue et
pour la littérature la poésie qui
existait
avant l'écriture à côté de l'écriture et
donc ensuite les formes prises par le
roman par exemple le roman c'est une
façon de raconter une histoire qui
appartient à l'Occident ou et bien on
cette forme là a été introduite au
moment de la colonisation et aujourd'hui
il y a des écrivains qui écrivent
exclusivement en langue vernaculaire
notamment en wallof au Sénégal alors pas
exclusivement j'ai en tête un écrivain
qui s'appelle Aboubacar Boris Diop ou
qui est écrit vre homonyme on partage le
même nom mais on n'est pas de la même
famille et lui s'illustre par cette
possibilité qu'il s'est donné à lui-même
d'écrire en français c'est un très bon
écrivain en français et d'écrit aussi en
également en wolof d'accord et il
traduit lui-même ses ses livres parfois
ces romans du français en wallof alors
la forme romanesque vous dites c'est le
long qu'il l'a apporté
euh c'est une forme je dirais
occidentale d'une certaine façon vous
c'est c'est votre principale façon de de
raconter et vous racontez en français
alors là vous êtes en langue française
est-ce que c'est votre univers la
francophonie vous alors déjà vous vous
en revendiquez ou au contraire est-ce
que c'est quelque chose
que et bien vous voulez arranger à votre
à votre façon
euh en fait la francophonie c'est c'est
une institution ma langue maternelle
c'est le français ma mère est française
et ce que je fais avec le
français c'est que j'en fais ma langue
d'écrivain et comme j'ai deux
sensibilités culturelles et bien je je
travaille le français pour y faire
entrer un autre horizon culturel et et
donc c'est un travail sur la langue
c'est un travail finalement
d'enrichissement de du français par euh
un contexte des univers culturels qui
sont très différents euh du de l'univers
culturel des Français de métropole h et
ça je l'appelle pas la Francophonie pour
moi c'est naturel en fait ou euh c'est
ma langue d'écrivain il y a un écrivain
qui que vous connaissez qui s'appelle
Amadou Kuruma Amadou kurumoma pour moi
qui est ivoirien lui hein lui il est
ivoirien et c'est un des premiers
écrivain de d'expression française qui
s'est approprié le français c'est-à-dire
que dans les années 60 70 il a vu son
premier manuscrit refusé parce qu'on
considérait que d'un point de vue
académique sa langue française sa langue
d'écrivain n'était pas correcte h HM il
a adapté le français il en a fait sa
langue d'écrivain pour faire rentrer son
univers culturel dans cette langue c'est
le premier à la différence des
anglophones qui sont beaucoup plus
libéraux de ce point de vue c'est le
premier à avoir euh travailler la langue
française sans avoir peur d'être pris
pour quelqu'un qui ne la maîtrisait pas
kurourumma c'est un des plus grands
écrivains euh africains donc d'origine
ivoirienne qui a écrit notamment Allah
n'est pas obligé qui a été un livre qui
a eu énormément de oui vous vous êtes
originaire d'un pays où il y avait une
figure tutellaire des lettres qui
s'appelait Léopold seddar sangor euh et
dans un livre qui a eu le prigoncour
vous vous avez eu prix concours des
lycéens on va en parler mais qui a eu le
prixoncours récemment c'est Mohamed
bougarsar Mohamed bougarsar parle de de
sangor disant que c'est un un héritage
encombrant est-ce que c'est votre
opinion aussi
euh alors non c'est c'est pas du tout
c'est Mohamed bougarsard qu'on voit en
photo qui est un jeune jeune écrivain et
brillant écrivain oui et un excellent
écrit oui oui
euh la figure tutellaire vous avez dit S
or euh non elle n'est pas
encombrante pour moi c'est-à-dire que
comme toute littérature il y a une
histoire qu'on peut euh faire commencer
avant saintgor et évidemment faire
prolongé après lui mais c'est quand même
un écrivain un poète qui est extrêmement
profond et qui à euh travailler lui
aussi à faire de la langue française
une langue africaine alors je disais
tout à l'heure en introduction que vos
livres sont des livres qui se promène
dans l'histoire de l'Afrique dans
l'histoire de votre pays du
Sénégal et il y a un président de la
République il y a une quinzaine d'années
qui a dit que justement l'Afrique
n'était pas rentré dans l'histoire c'est
Nicolas Sarkozi c'était un discours
qu'il a prononcé en
2007 à Dakar vous avez été heurté par ce
discours où euh qu'est-ce que vous en
avez pensé alors je suis enseignant de
littérature du 18e siècleunivité de à
l'université de peau et et et je
travaille sur des récits de voyage euh
qui ont été écrits par euh euh des
voyageurs du 17e ou 18e siècle français
mais européen ouais et c'était une
époque où en effet on disait que
l'histoire n'avait pas d'Afrique et donc
quand j'ai entendu ce discours j'ai cru
entendre des choses qui ont été dites il
y a très longtemps ah d'accord et sur
lesquelles
en fait Nicolas Sarkozi ne fait que
répéter ce qu' se disait alors peut-être
qu' il a été inspiré peut-être par son
conseiller de l'époque h ou oui mais
alors de quelle histoire parle-t-on
aussi entrer dans l'histoire l'Afrique a
une histoire millénaire et donc je
trouvais que c'était extrêmement
maladroit d'ailleurs à l'université
chantodiop il y a des universitair qui
assistai à ce discours et qui ayant
entendu ces phrases se sont levé et ont
quitté la salle la salle alors vous vous
avez eu je le disais tout à l'heure le
prixoncours des lycéens c'était en 2018
avec un livre qui a un titre magnifique
vous avez le don des titres d'ailleurs
frère d'ame hein et c'est une plongée
dans l'univers des tirailleur sénégalais
et alors ce que je crois savoir c'est
que en fait c'est pas la rencontre de
tirailleur sénégalais qui vous a inspiré
ce
livre pas du tout c'est votre arrière
grand-père maternel qui lui Landais et
qui avait fait la guerre 1418 oui oui
oui alors je ne l'ai pas compris
immédiatement c'est-à-dire que après
lapparution de frèredame j'ai eu à
répondre à des interviews comme
aujourd'hui et petit à petit je me suis
rendu compte que il fallait que je
réfléchisse sur les raisons pour
lesquelles j'avais choisi d'écrire un
livre mettant en scène un combattant de
la Première Guerre mondiale et je me
suis rappelé que ma mère disait que mon
arrière- grand-père donc était Landé et
bien était parti à la guerre et était
revenu avait été blessé assez gravement
parce qu'il a été gazé à l'yérite et
n'avait jamais rien dit sur ce qu'il
avait vécu et je pense que je me suis
intéressé à cette première guerre
mondiale grâce ou à cause de lui h et
quand j'ai pensé écrire un roman mettant
en scène un tirailleur sénégalais en
fait dans fond peut-être j'essayis de
combler ce silence h et je me suis
demandé depuis s'il avait rencontré des
tirailleurs sénégalais c'est tout à fait
possible mais comme j'ai deux
sensibilités culturelles il y a eu un
pont qui s'est fait entre cet homme-l et
ce tirailleur sénégalais de fiction que
j'ai inventé alors il faut le dire c'est
un c'est un livre absolument terrible
tragique un des deux tirailleurs
sénégalais dont vous parlez qui est qui
défourille comme on dirait
aujourd'hui comme quoi quand on parle de
l'Afrique souvent ça on a l'impression
que ça ne peut-être que tragique parce
que vous avez fait un autre livre vous
en avez fait plusieurs de livres mais
vous avez fait un autre livre euh
récemment là qui é qui a beaucoup de
succès la la porte du voyage sans retour
et et là on plonge alors dans une autre
histoire qui est tragique aussi Qui est
qui est l'histoire bah de Goré de l'île
de Goré qui est en face de Dakar et d'où
partaient des bateaux remplis de de
d'esclave qui prenaient le chemin euh de
l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique alors c'est c'est est
tragique peut-être en effet parce que je
situe mes romans pour l'instant dans une
période coloniale c'est-à-dire que la
colonisation est toujours violente et
elle elle violente les peuples mais elle
violente aussi les les individus H qui
s'inscrivent dans une histoire tragique
une histoire personnelle tragique une
histoire qui une grande histoire avec
une grand hache qui les qui les qui les
opprime euh mais donc ça ça peut changer
pour l'instant c'est ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de
finalement placer des personnages dans
un contexte historique difficile et
essayer par la force de l'écriture ou de
la fiction de comprendre comment ils ont
pu échapper à des contradictions ou au
contraire tomber dans des contradictions
euh dans une vie qui n'était pas simple
alors si vous me permettez la tragédie
continue quand on voit le le drame que
vivent tous ces ces exilés qui prennent
la route de de l'Europe ou des
États-Unis avec des moyens de fortune
qui meurent dans la Méditerranée et puis
après dans la Manche quand ils vont vers
la vers
l'Angleterre ça continue ce drame
finalement de l'exil
oui oui c'est c'est un drame universel
ça pourrait vousous inspirer ça ça a
inspiré beaucoup de romans déjà
et le sujet est peut-être tellement
grave et tellement douloureux qu'il est
très difficile en tout cas pour
moi de travailler sur ces sujets là sans
qu'il y ait une distance h pour
frère-dame autant que pour la porte du
voyage sans retour j'ai l'histoire
justement qui fait
distance c'est-à-dire qui me permet
finalement de me retourner et de
réfléchir au sens propre du terme tandis
que l'actualité brûlante elle est
extrême douloureuse elle est très proche
et elle ne me laisse pas le temps en
fait d'y revenir pour en tirer quelque
chose qui ne serait pas de l'ordre du
témoignage mais de la création
littéraire aussi de la fiction quand
vous lisez les témoignages de ces gens
qui partent et qui traversent la
Méditerranée qui arrivent à la traverser
et bien ce sont des témoignages mais qui
sont qui qui dépasse
l'imagination là la vraiment la réalité
dépasse la fiction dans dans l'horreur
et donc je n'ai rien à ajouter à cela si
ce n'est déploré dans le fond c'est
c'est cette nouvelle souffrance ces
souffrance infinie que aujourd'hui
l'Afrique est peuplée d'environ 1
milliard 200 ou 300 millions d'habitants
on dit que d'ici à 25 ans il y en aura 2
milliards est-ce que est-ce que les
Africains sont condamnés à
l'exil non non non vous êtes pas
pessimiste à ce point-là alors il faut
peut-être
aller au-delà de cette antithèse entre
l'optimisme et le pessimisme oui
c'est-à-dire que on ne peut pas
prévoir de quoi l'avenir sera fait on
peut avoir des évolutions absolument
inimaginable et donc moi je me garderais
bien de faire de la
prospective je sais que l'Afrique c'est
tellement est tellement diverse il y a
tellement de situations différentes il y
a aussi une force qui est appartient à
l'Afrique c'est qu'elle comme vous venez
de le dire elle a une jeunesse qui
explose et qui est extrêmement dynamique
euh donc je ne peux pas dire si je suis
optimiste ou pessimiste je peux
simplement dire qu'il faut avoir
l'espoir que les choses s'arrange alors
vous vous partagez pas cette phrase que
je trouve assez extraordinaire de d'Alam
bancou qui dit que le danger pour
l'écrivain noir est s'enfermer dans sa
noirceur vous la connaissez cette
expression bien sûr al oui alors c'est
peut-être être en danger mais
c'està-dire que pour ressentir ou avoir
le sentiment qu'il y a danger il faut
affronter ce danger ou le rencontrer moi
j'ai pas
l'impression de devoir éviter des
écueils dans le fond je me sens très
tranquille par rapport à l'écriture euh
très tranquille par rapport au choix que
je pourrais faire je suis pas dans une
démarche où je serai aliéné par mes
sujets parce que ma bancou dit aussi il
faut en finir avec les sanglots de
l'homme noir comme Bruckner disait
sanglot de l'homme
blanc vous êtes d'accord avec ça il faut
peut-êre dans mes romans en tout cas mes
personnages ne se plaignent
pas ils vivent leur vie fictive en fait
et ce qui moi me m'intéresse en tout cas
dans ma façon d'aborder la littérature
c'est dans le fond de donner des
éléments au lecteur pour que il se fasse
à partir de sa propre imagination une
idée du monde dans lequel je veux le
plonger c'est ça euh j'ai pas de message
particulier nêtes pas un romancier
engagé vous avez pas de message à faire
passer précisément euh non euh si ce
n'est pour déplorer comme beaucoup
d'autres comme on le disait tout à
l'heure par exemple le drame que vivent
ces ces migrants qui traversent la
Méditerranée central et au sujet
desqueles on m'a demandé de faire un
article dans le New York Times ou dans
le monde là je je me suis senti obligé
d'une certaine façon de témoigner euh de
ce que cette situation était
horrible mais la littérature pour moi
elle elle a elle a plusieurs façons
peut-être d'aborder des thématiques
universelles pas nécessairement
africaines d'ailleurs qui peuvent
toucher le lecteur les mouvoir sans
qu'il soit dit que il faille faire du
didactisme et un enseignement qui serait
assainé comme cela au lect
Voltaire dit dans un son Dictionnaire
philosophique que selon lui les livres
les plus utiles sont ceux dont les
lecteurs font eux même la moitié
c'est très joli ça et et donc vous avez
beaucoup de distance par rapport au
wisme à la canelle culture c'est pas
votre c'est pas du tout votre sujet ça
vous condamnez ça d'ailleurs cette
remise en question de
l'histoire alors moi je condamne ce que
je connais c'est-à-dire que je ne sais
pas exactement ce qui est le
wisme j'entends deci de là qu'il y a
beaucoup de définitions qui sont données
euh ce que je trouve quand même
appréciable peut-être dans ce qu'on
appelle le wokisme mais qui peut-être
s'appelait autrement avant et c'est
cette capacité qu'on peut souffrir à
soi-même de réfléchir sur ce qui est
présenté comme
étant dogmatique c'est-à-dire une
représentation on va dire de l'histoire
du monde euh qui peut en effet être
construite en Europe et peut-être
déconstruite ailleurs il y a un penseur
que qui est vraiment très important en
France qui est Michel foucco qui a
construit des outils
d'analyse de certaines périodes de
l'histoire des idées et notamment le
régime de véridiction il il explique que
chaque période historique en Europe et
bien se construit un
régime de pensé dans lequel on admet à
un moment donné que telle chose est
vraie et que telle chose est fausse et
j'aime beaucoup cette façon d'aborder
les moments de l'histoire il est
possible qu'en ce moment et bien on
change de régime de véridiction par
rapport à des choses qu'on pensa vous
app ça comme la véridiction voilà
véridiction en régime de véridiction oui
alors vous êtes métis puisque votre mère
donc est française votre père est
sénégalais quelque part vous avez écrit
que le métissage c'est une ciliation
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire par là
c'està-dire que en tout cas moi je l'ai
je l'ai vécu comme ça et et mon frère et
ma sœur aussi je pense on est dans une
famille où on a la chance de recevoir
l'affection autant des parents de de ma
mère que ceux de mon père c'est une
chance c'est c'est c'est pas applicable
ou généralisable mais c'est dans mon
histoire personnelle voulez dire que ce
sont deux cultures qui se sont
rencontrés et qui ont vécu en osmose
c'està-dire où il n'y a pas eu
d'antagonisme c'est-à-dire est rare non
alors je n'en sais rien je ne parle que
de mon expérience personnelle c'est pour
ça que j'ai dit qu'il y a conciliation
c'est pour éviter de dire que le
métissage nécessirement peut surgir d'un
anagonisme il y a pas eu d'antagonisme
j'ai reçu de l'affection au Sénégal et
en France et donc c'est un cas personnel
vous avez une très belle dédicace
d'ailleurs dans frèredame vous dites
à mes parents passeur de vie métisse
c'est magnifique ça comme comme hommage
oui euh je je trouve que on a eu un
univers dans lequel on
a finalement fait se rencontrer de
culture différentes avec beaucoup
d'aménité beaucoup d'ouverture d'esprit
en fait en effet ils nous ont appris nos
parents autant mon père que ma mère à
nous ouvrir à d'autres réalités et ça je
trouve que c'est un très grand cadeau
qu'ils nous ont fait est-ce que c'est
pour ça que vous enseigné beaucoup le
18e siècle à l'université de poau oui
tout le monde sait le 18e siècle c'est
le siècle de l'universel oui ça peut
s'expliquer aussi par vos origines par
ce métissage euh peut-être peut-être moi
ce que j'aime dans Voltaire c'est son
côté
insolent et j'ai cité Voltaire mais il y
a pas que Voltaire la littérature du 18e
siècle c'est une littérature quand même
qu'il faut replacer dans un contexte
précis où en effet il y avait une
oppression contre laquelle les
philosophes ont lutté
et une oppression qui a conduit à
l'expression de grandes idées autour des
droits de l'homme et donc on leur doit
beaucoup euh mais c'est le siècle aussi
le 18e siècle du pic de l'esclavage
transatlantique oui c'est le commerce
triangulaire ce que dénoncé monesquieux
voà la bérénale dis
exactement celui qui je pense qui le
dénonçait le plus clairement c'était
didro did mais bon ceci dit ce qui m'a
plu dans ce siècle c'est son côté
contestataire cette remise en cause des
idées reçues et puis ce qui me plaît
aussi dans la littérature du 18e siècle
c'est que c'est une
littérature qui a su s'adapter à ce que
nous ne connaissons peut-être pas
aujourd'hui encore ou qui apparaî sous
d'autres formes à la censure c'est une
littérature qui tire aussi sa grandeur
des stratégies le contournement de la
censure qui qu'elle a opéré alors je
voudrais vous soumettre une phrase de
sangor qui a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre l'émotion est et la la la
raison etélè qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez etélen était é grec puis qu'il
était passionné de de anciennes oui oui
oui alors c'est une phrase qui a suscité
évidemment beaucoup de
réactions parce que ça elle était
considéré et puis on peut le dire d'une
certaine manière à juste titre he comme
étant un peu une caricature de la
négritude par rapport à l'éninité ou le
monde
greco-romain moi je replace cette phrase
dans un
contexte à la fois politique et
littéraire saingor écrit cela au moment
du mouvement de la
négritude il essaie de trouver ce qui
fait euh justement cette négritude et
donc il il travaille il réfléchit sur la
façon d'exprimer euh cette idée là euh
mais c'est une phrase qui a suscité
beaucoup de de réactions j'ai entendu
suleimman Bachir Diagne ici même
expliquer et je rejoins son point de vue
qu'il faut replacer cette phrase dans la
connaissance qu'avit saingor de du
philosophe
de Beron voilà qu'il fallait la lire
cette phrase de cette façonlà mais d'une
manière générale tous les marxistes
léniniste des années de ces années-là
africains hein et bien on considérait
que c'était une phrase qui était
absolument détestable et que c'était la
manifestation de l'esprit bourgeois de
Saint-Gor la négritude quuma l'a dit
très clair le premier
président Ghana qui était marxiste
liniste a rejeté absolument cette cette
phrase là David Diop est-ce que vous
avez une musique africaine que vous
préférez qui est votre élu du cœur oui
j'aime bien la musique sénégalaise
dansensemble le Malard Leard ou et puis
j'aime bien les les morceaux anciens qu
que j'entendais pendant ma jeunesse
notamment celui de
l'orchest
ou qui veut dire la mort est certaine en
fait c'est pas très
gays mais elle me fait penser à des
moments à la fois triste et heureux
c'est définition même de la nostalgie
vous êtes nostalgique oui je suis très
nostalgique et vous êtes nostalgique de
vos années sénégalaises quand vous étiez
petit enfant à l'école là-bas voilà
c'est ça c'estd à la fois
nostalgique d'une époque qui sera
Absolum Révol
quand je pense à mes parents je vois
jeune en entendant cette musique
d'accord mais c'est pas une nostalgie
irrédiable c'estàdire qui me plongerait
dans une sorte de désespoir aujourd'hui
vous êtes optimiste pour le Sénégal et
l'Afrique oui merci David je vous en
[Musique]
prie